from the very first to hand in their
letters of no confidence to more recent
rebels 28 mps want boris johnson to go
now
and today andrea ledson a long-time
johnson supporter said there have been
unacceptable failings of leadership
now the government standards watchdog
lord geit says there's a legitimate
question over whether boris johnson
broke the ministerial code he said i've
repeatedly counseled the prime
minister's official and political
advisers that the prime minister should
be ready to offer public comment on his
obligations under the ministerial code
even if he's judged himself not to be in
breach that advice has not been heeded
he said and in relation to the
allegations of unlawful gatherings in
downing street the prime minister has
made not a single public reference to
the ministerial code they know me well
enough to know if i made my mind up it
wasn't likely to change senior tories
are braced for a vote of confidence as
soon as next week of course it's
potential and of course
we've seen as a number of people are
expressing similar concerns albeit that
these are people who come from uh very
different um traditions within the
conservative party it goes right across
the party and from what you've heard do
you think there are people that aren't
speaking out publicly that might already
be putting their letters in
i think that's more than likely on the
doorstep when i was out in most days a
lot of traditional researchers were
saying look this is bringing
politics into distribute
we're not prepared to support the
conservative party
whilst the prime minister remains as its
leader
ministers are rallying but even they're
not sure the prime minister will survive
i spend my time in the department rather
than in the tea room
uh but i hear the news you can see
letters coming in but in the end you
know prime ministers are constantly
juggling
uh to maintain mandate and to maintain
trust and sometimes it comes to a head
like this if a confidence vote was
called this week perhaps next week boris
johnson would win
um honestly you'd have to spend as much
time as you do talking to my colleagues
to know the answer to that i just don't
know i'm honestly i'm 15 16 our days in
the department i don't know where back
bench colleagues are if 54 letters go in
boris johnson will be told straight away
in theory a confidence vote where he'd
need the support of the majority of his
mps would then happen as soon as
possible when the threshold was met
under theresa may a vote was held that
night but the rebels this time aren't an
organized faction it feels uncoordinated
and therefore unpredictable some are
angry about the idea of a windfall tax
others aren't happy with party
management but what is concerning many
tory mps is cut through has the great
vote winner boris johnson lost his touch
with the electorate
some of boris johnson's allies are
confident if it comes to it he'd win a
confidence vote but trust is hard to win
back the prime minister may be bruised
beyond repair ali fortescue sky news